[Music]
well thank you thank you very much for
coming to a talk which has a really
strange sounding title emotional
education we're very used to the idea
that we need to get educated in certain
sorts of skills maths Latin geography
physics accountancy but the notion that
we need to be educated in our emotional
functioning is very peculiar surely we
know about our emotions our capacities
to love and to hate to feel anxious and
to feel calm to direct our lives as we
would wish surely we know all that stuff
we don't need an education in the
pursuit of a fulfilled emotional life
but let me ask you just a question to
see if we can just probe that um who in
this room is happy to be married but not
in love married but not in love any of
you happy to be married but not you know
tolerating tolerating the partner he's
nice as you turn towards his okay
alright but what we're what we're
sensing is that there is a broad
consensus that you guys would like to be
married and happy okay interesting
who here is happy to be in a job where
you're earning money but you're not
fulfilled okay a few people but broadly
speaking this is why you need an
emotional education because you have
very high expectations it's very very
hard to be married and happy it's very
very hard to be in a job and fulfilled
not merely earning money these are new
expectations that we have of our lives
and yet we continue to cling to an
ancient model that somehow the knack for
knowing how to pull off a successful
emotional life is something that we
should pick up by intuition ten years
ago with colleagues I started up an
organization called the school of life
I'm here to present a new book which is
simply called the school of life an
emotional education it's ten years worth
of our thinking around the business of
how we might become emotional adults you
know how to become an adult you just eat
cereal and food and and wait for time to
pass and you'll
an emotional adult is a different thing
most of us will be pushing 300 years old
before we've really got the hang of it
and but it's an aspiration
you know we're operating in a world in
which religion no longer guides us as it
once did and it's within the context of
a secularizing world that I and
colleague set up the school of life you
know when religion first went into
decline in the mid 19th century in
England in other parts of Western Europe
people asked where were people going to
get the emotional and spiritual guidance
that churches had once given and there
was a legitimate sense that there was
going to be trouble because we are all
mortal
we need consolation we're isolated we're
lonely we're confused and the churches
for better and for worse dispensed
guidance in these areas where was that
going to come from if it worked out if
one worked out that the whole story the
biblical story was scientifically
speaking nonsense well one answer came
to the fore that culture would replace
Scripture and that's why there was an
extraordinary boom in the development of
the humanities in the 19th century giant
libraries were built theaters were built
university courses in the arts were
started for the very first time and a
huge push was made towards the idea that
what we have previously been able to
gain from religion we would now be able
to source from the plays of Shakespeare
the novels of Jane Austen the the
paintings of Rembrandt or Caravaggio
that these sort of things would be able
to give us what previous ages it found
in religion it's a lovely idea
partly is why we're here today you know
this is in some ways part of what we're
doing by gathering but without any
insult on the fantastic hosts of this
festival and giant done real success of
this festival
broadly speaking culture has not
replaced Scripture and you know this
because if you show up at the Tate
Modern and you go on your knees and you
say I'm lost I don't know how to live I
I'm confused redeem me you will be very
swiftly ushered out by some guards this
is
simply not what you can do or we show up
at the University of Oxford and you're
reading philosophy say the home of the
largest questions you say I don't know
where I should seek guidance for the
largest questions um how can I be good
how can I make sure my life is properly
led again they would look at you very
strangely one could say that those who
are the guardians of culture in our
society have a certain coolness about
them it's as though the sort of people
who they're imagine dealing with don't
wake up at 3:00 in the morning as many
of us here do I hope wondering what on
earth it's all about and what we meant
to be doing on on this planet there's a
sort of sense that most of us know how
to live well the starting assumption of
a school of life is of course we don't
know how to live and and we need
guidance now there is of course an
industry devoted to guidance in this
area it's called the self-help industry
now being sophisticated and intelligent
and cultured people all of you will have
steered well clear of anything redolent
of the term self-help I mean it's really
it's a it's a horror term it's often
associated forgive me if there are any
Californians in the room with a sort of
naive West Coast utopianism that covers
a garish the promises are overblown
there's a sort of sense of you know you
can change your love life in five
minutes of the perfect sex life made a
million dollars in a yeah et cetera in
other words overblown naive sentimental
promises designed to cover up a much
harder reality now the starting point of
the school of life is that actually
trying to tell people that life is a
perfect business that can be made ideal
is one of the quickest ways to depress
them the best way to cheer anyone up is
to tell them life is difficult for
everyone we suffer all of us alone
thinking that we are massively unique in
our sufferings we're not they're
actually what binds us together and
being able therefore to say we are a
broken species is the first step towards
consolation and an act of friendship
all religions knew this move I mean
think of Buddhism the first tenet of
Buddhism is life is suffering well
thanks very much it goes and it goes on
from there and the grimness of existence
far from an ignorant of that grimness
being a route to ultimate despair it's
actually the birth of compassion towards
ourselves and compassion towards our
knowing that we are broken creatures as
I say is a sort of beginning of a
friendship it also makes you a nicer
person imagine two people on a dinner
date right they do and met each other
they don't know each other well and one
of them starts saying well I'm pretty
perfect and the other one goes I'm
pretty perfect too and my job's doing
well the other one goes well you know
things been going pretty great for me
too insufferable a rigid insufferable
perfectionism how much nicer it would be
if this couple got together and they
said how are you crazy I'm crazy in
these ways how about your brokenness
what's your brokenness look like and
they were able to build friendship and
and a sense of neutrality precisely on
on an acknowledgment of how much in them
was not perfect isn't it I should say
the goal of life is not the god of
emotional life should never be to try
and be entirely sane there are no sane
people we've done some surveys we've
sent out scouts no one is saying on the
earth however the best possible kind of
sanity you can aim for is what we like
to call sane insanity whereby you have
what we might call a handle on what's
wrong with you there's still something
wrong with you because there's something
wrong with everybody
but you can describe it in eloquent and
reassuring terms to those who you live
near with and if you don't want to harm
too much that is the best that we can do
but it's a lot and this is in many ways
the goal of the self-help that the
school of life dispensed it were
uniquely we like to think quietly pre
brexit we're quite a English institution
in the sense that one of the great
exports of this country traditionally
was always melancholy and melancholy
melancholy is not sadness or despair nor
is it rage and or is it bitterness it's
it's it's an elegant negotiation with
tragedy and I think that that's what we
might be able to to aim for um we live
in a cruel world and I'll tell you how
cruel it is because one of the first
questions that we face whenever we meet
somebody new is what do you do and
according to how you answer that
question people are the incredibly
pleased to see you or a little bit
fearful and just leave you alone by the
nuts and you know that you are not going
to get the respect the kindness the
honor that
of us crave because you have not
performed well enough in a very
fast-moving very competitive capitalist
economy and this is hardwired into us
with a conscious of it or not we know
that's the way it is and the opposite so
I should say this um in a way we live in
a world of snobs
now snobbery is often associated with an
old-fashioned English concern with
aristocracy with titles dukedoms etc and
that the snob is on the lookout for
someone with certain lineage and
bloodline no one's a snob like that
anymore or five people on the planet the
dominant form of snobbery nowadays is of
course job snobbery and snobbery is any
way of judging another human being
whereby you take a small and arguably
not central part of them and use that to
come to a rigid non-negotiable verdict
on who they are and so for the snob if
you meet a clothes snob for example you
can say to them you know my trousers are
from the gap that's it you know you
could be the nicest person most
interesting person finished right and so
you know it's now the the opposite of a
snob is your mother not necessarily your
mother or need my mother but but doesn't
what the ideal mother she doesn't care
how you're doing how you're performing
she cares how you are ideally ideally
but most people are not our mothers most
people judge very quickly and we feel
that judgment is lovely called
frightening quote from George Orwell who
says after 20 no one cares if you're
nice or not and that captures something
rather tragic you know nowadays we often
hear critics saying that we live in
incredibly materialistic times that
never before people being so greedy and
focused on acquiring money I don't think
that we're living in particularly
materialistic times I think we're living
in times that have for a whole variety
of reasons connected up emotional
rewards to the possession of material
goods it's not ultimately the material
goods that we want it's the emotional
rewards that we feel rightly that there
are conduit to that we're after but we
know that we can't get to them without
first passing through the gate of
material success and that in a way lends
a certain point even see to the way in
which we pursue material success
and the way in which our eagerness for
material and status Goods plays itself
out I mean look you know to be
compassionate the next time you see
somebody driving by in a Ferrari don't
think this is somebody you know who's
very greedy think this is somebody with
an unusually intense and very poignant
need for love that they're expressing
you know through through automotive
means um many many features of society
nowadays are almost designed to ramp up
the tension that we feel all of us feel
and that we pick up at the school of
life one of those things is the notion
that nowadays we live in a meritocracy
now meritocracy is one of those words
that politicians on left and right of
the spectrum are really keen on your
view at all saying that the the gold and
no varner of their political efforts is
to create a more meritocratic world now
let's try none pick that word for a
moment what do people mean by
meritocracy they mean a society where
those who deserve certain rewards will
get them that merit will lead to certain
kinds of success if you're hard-working
it doesn't matter who your parents were
where you went to school you should be
able to get to the top um
this sounds fantastic I mean who on
earth would ever argue with this idea
but there's a very nasty sting in the
tail that carries a big psychological
burden if you genuinely believe in a
world in which those who get to the top
deserve to get to the top you'll also be
creating logically
a world in which those who are at the
bottom deserve to be at the bottom in
other words a meritocratic worldview
turns success but also failure from
something that might have been a chance
phenomenon to something that is
determined and says a huge amount about
who you are and this is very different
from all other societies most other
societies have ascribed what happens to
a person over their life at least in
part at least half to the intervention
of non-human forces let's call them
divine we don't have to believe in these
divine forces to know that that's what
previous societies
so if you look at ancient Rome for
example so ancient Rome had a cult of
the goddess of fortune she was known as
Fortuna and they were estimated to have
been over 8,000 shrines and statues of
Fortuna in public places across Roman
Italy and the notion was that if
something went right for you in your
life or if you had a difficult moment
coming up you would immediately go and
pray and give an offering to the goddess
of fortune because what happened in your
endeavor was held to reside at least
substantially in the hands of this
goddess this goddess was represented in
an interesting way
she was depicted holding a cornucopia
which was filled with the symbols of
prosperity and success and worldly
glamour so money and fruit and and
medals and other such things and then in
her other hand she was depicted holding
a tiller and this was meant to represent
a capacity to change very likely with a
light touch of her hand the course of
men and women's lives
so she was held to be fickle have
immense power over us and and distribute
her favors slightly willy-nilly as the
mood took her so forth the goddess of
fortune a central figure we don't
believe in fortune anymore we don't
believe in luck anymore you pick this up
in language you know in medieval English
if you came across somebody who had
absolutely no financial resources the
word that you would use to describe them
was an unfortunate literally somebody
not blessed by the goddess of fortune
unfortunate nowadays taking the United
States what you call such a person a
loser a bit of a loser and feel the
punitive quality of that term loser
loser is what you get when a society
thinks it's running a race that that
race is broadly speaking fair now what
does it matter if if if this happens
well not believing in luck makes life a
lot tougher for example if I said you
know I I published this book and it's
very very good but unfortunately it's
sold no copies but the problem is it's
not my problem it's Fortuna the goddess
of fortune has somehow not blessed my
book but it's really very good
you'd go no no that's not true you've
done something wrong you
would say how can the guy be telling me
that he has value and there is no
external reward for that value it's
hardwired into us that's what it means
to live in that period of history that
historians call modernity and modernity
as an idea as an ideology was thought to
have begun at some point in the tail end
of the 19th century and one of the first
great students of the mentality of
modernity was the French sociologist
Emile Durkheim and has a fascinating
role to play in this story because
Durkheim studied many of the differences
between agrarian societies and
industrial societies in other words
societies that live together in villages
where most of the money was earned
through agriculture where people
believed in God and where family kinship
clans were very important and he
controlled started this with modern
societies where people live in cities
where money's earned it often in large
anonymous factories where people are not
connected up with large family groupings
but are often isolated in romantic dyads
and he contrasted these and maybe lots
of fascinating observations but there
was one which continues to stick out and
in a way haunts the modern imagination
and it's this the rate of people killing
themselves in modern societies is 20
times as high as that in pre in agrarian
societies in other words despite all the
advantages in modernity something is a
little awry and that something is was
very clear to Durkheim which is modern
societies ascribe people's biography
solely to them you are a success you are
a failure not the gods not your family
not where you came from doesn't matter
about any of that it's how you're
performing and because of capitalism in
the way it works and the fact that there
must always be victims and
inefficiencies that are weeded out and
this is going to leave a certain number
of people every year who cannot face
what they've become in the eyes of
others their need for respect and for
honor is not going to ever be realized
and and the only way out is the most
tragic way that humans know look in a
way a lot of what we do
when we try and succeed in life is by
the goodwill of other people right
that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to by the kindness of strangers
we're trying to ensure that when we walk
in a room people are not ashamed and
embarrassed and look the other way we're
trying to hope that when when somebody
greets us there will be a certain energy
to their greeting now here's the good
and bad news right for those of you who
are on that treadmill and many of us are
you know it's a very natural path it
doesn't really work it sort of works but
actually you know you could be the
richest person in Britain if you're
obnoxious no one really wants to know
you this sort of pay a certain amount of
respect but not really ultimately and
this is a sort of strange secret um you
know the thing that really turns
strangers into friends and it sounds
very odd because we think it's the
opposite right failure vulnerability the
display of vulnerability is actually the
only route to friendship you cannot
become friends with any human being on
the planet without showing a bit of
yourself which they could use against
you which they could use to humiliate
you which is in some ways in the eyes of
the so-called world embarrassing but
that's the beginning of friendship and
we almost forget about this I think we
know it in our hearts but we forget
about it
we don't live as though that's true we
live as though a shiny glossy thing is
going to get us the friendship we need
it's not actually it's a root it's a
one-way road to isolation I want to put
this idea to the test
some of you know each other but some of
you don't what I want you to do when I
give you the signal and not any time
before is I want you to turn to somebody
maybe that you don't know that you
haven't come here with a stranger a
stranger and I want you to very briefly
introduce yourself shake their hand and
then I want you to do a very strange
sounding thing I want you to tell them
very briefly something you regret
something you're ashamed of
and something you're sad about something
you regret something you're ashamed of
and something you're sad about and we've
got two minutes for this introduce
yourself to a stranger now
[Music]
okay all right let's set let's come back
let's come back into the room you're
enjoying this okay
um let's let's all come back let's all
come back so you know thank you thank
you thank you I think we have to stop it
there how'd you stop with that guys help
me out all right the reason why the
reason why this feels good is that so
many of us spend so much of the time
feeling a bit weird how how many of you
feel a bit weird sometimes so so so
maybe maybe we've got a week maybe got a
room about 150 weird people
which-which oh she's quite reassuring
because not hungry people can't be weird
that statistics are against that a
conclusion it's something else is going
on the problem is that we know other
people only from what they choose to
tell us whereas we know ourselves from
the inside so we know all the turmoil
and the anxiety and the regrets and the
shame we know all of that but we know
other people only from what they choose
to tell us and because of the way that
life is set up they're sort of hi how
are you doing I'm great how you doing
I'm great how you doing I'm gonna kill
myself how you doing fantastic um
because of that culture we don't get to
share enough of our inner lives and
we're slowly going mad for no reason at
all so if ever you feel lonely isolated
vulnerable do the one thing you don't
really feel like doing lean into the
vulnerability and dare to believe that
others are as troubled by this strange
business we call life as you are a great
source of relief you know we're on the
edge of London part of what drives us
nuts in the modern world is that we live
in cities were connected constantly by
social media we know so much about what
other human beings are up to their
achievements their triumphs their
ambitions right it drives us mad all
other societies other than our own had
bang in the middle something mightier
holier greater than human beings
something non-human that was venerated
and was greater than the king that was
greater than all the bishops that was
greater than all the noblemen and the
aristocracy we've done away with that
the only thing at the centre of our
societies is other human beings and
their triumphs and their great moments
no wonder we're driven slightly crazy
we need moments of relief one of the
things we need more than ever almost
without realizing how much we need it is
the spectacle of nature not for the
business of being healthy though that -
it's about being psychologically healthy
the great thing about nature is it
doesn't care about you it doesn't care
about the leadership election and brexit
and the finances etc it is a nonhuman
world that will endure far after our
human show will have ended and it
relative eise's us we have such trouble
finding perspective in relation to our
own troubles that's why we enjoy seeing
oceans and glaciers and mighty mountains
and hearing Brian Cox and looking up at
the stars we need this so badly we need
the stars more than they'll ever need us
we need we've dogs dogs are fantastic
about this the great thing about a dog
is it doesn't mind how things are going
at the office right all it wants to do
is just play with you and you throw it a
ball that comes back little children
children under 4 a fantastic in this
regard as well they don't mind they just
care if you're gonna be nice right and
and and this is extremely important so
being somehow relativized ok and moving
on I want to talk about self-knowledge
it's a big thing that we talk about here
the most central command of ancient
philosophy when Socrates was said what's
the one thing that everyone needs to
know a philosophy he replied rather no
mclee know yourself that somehow
self-knowledge is at the root of being
an enlightened person now I might say
well surely we know ourselves because
like we're ourselves so surely I know me
you know why would you claim to know me
because I'm me so surely I know me the
weird thing is it's very very hard to
achieve self-knowledge if you compared
the mind it would be like a gigantic
house that was plunged in darkness we
don't know most of the rooms most of the
rooms are bolted shut
often by fear and we're somewhere in
operatic in a cupboard with a little
torch and that's called consciousness
and occasionally will sort of shine the
light and try and work out what's what's
going on but broadly our grasp of
ourselves is incredibly fragile and and
tentative largely because or in part
because the things that there are to
know about us are so scary there's so
anxiety inducing and unfortunately we've
built a world where we can escape the
business of introspection far better
than we almost have ever been able to do
I mean you can work out a life where you
need never ever be alone what's wrong
with our phones is not that we're gaming
on them with all having fun on them that
the problem is they don't allow us
enough time with our thoughts I wonder
how many of you sleep well you know
there's been an epidemic of insomnia and
now what is insomnia in my view insomnia
is really the minds revenge for all
those thoughts that you in inverted
commas forgot to have in the day all
those thoughts about your regrets and
your longings and your shame and your
desires and all those things
that you carefully plotted not to ever
confront are gonna come and get you in
the middle of the night so if you really
want to sleep think more allow more time
for thought in the in the other hours of
your life and and other addictions are
possible addictions to news to to travel
to work a lot of respectable sounding
reasons why we need never explore
ourselves look most childhoods have gone
a bit wrong without anyone meaning for
anything bad to happen most of us have a
childhood which has been difficult now
why on earth am i mentioning childhood
at this juncture and some of you in the
room might go hang on a minute he's not
gonna mention that guy Freud surely we
know isn't over I often get asked isn't
Freud finished like that wasn't wasn't
he discredited it wasn't you know and
the bad news and it really really is bad
news and I mentioned this is a great fan
of Freud the bad news is that guys not
going away the insight that he made
about human emotional functioning is
fundamental and will even if lots of his
theories are going to be discredited or
improved upon or worked upon the
fundamental one which is that the way
that we are as adult sits upon a base
formed in childhood and that the
childhood relationships the central
relationships that we had with our
caregivers and parental figures that
these are the golden key to unlocking
our emotional functioning this is not
going to go away anytime soon
and it's a problem it's humiliating
frankly you could be 30 40 50 60 70 and
you're asking me to believe that who I
was at five is determining so much I'm
afraid yes it really is and and the best
way is not to try and run away or
ridicule or scoff at this notion but to
accept it on the chin and do that one
thing that will get us out of merely
acting out our childhood patterns and
our childhood dynamics and that is
understanding the more you can
understand a dynamic the more you could
pull the plug out of it and diffuse it
you know what are some of the ways in
which childhoods go wrong I'm speaking
with my son in the room so block your
ears Samuel okay this is one way in
which childhoods go wrong you know I'm
borrowing heavily here from a
psychoanalyst that I'm very fond or with
very keen on at the school of life his
name was Donald Winnicott he was working
at Paddington Green Children's Hospital
in the 50s 60s and 70s
made amazing progress in basically
turning britain from a parent focused
parenting model towards a child focused
parenting model in other words that a
good parent now for the first time sees
the child as a human being rather than
as an animal that needs to be watered
and fed and the notion of being attuned
to a child's needs was something
Winnicott believed in very much now but
he observed something very important and
very interesting he argued that in the
early years every child has what he
called a true self and that true self is
fundamentally a social appoints
anti-social
in other words it's not interested in
being good and polite and sweet it may
sometimes be good in polite and sweet
but not for the sake of being good and
polite and sweet it is simply an
authentic being trying to figure out the
world on its own terms and so sometimes
that means that baby will be happy and
smiley and sometimes baby will be
furious and kicking and biting and
wanted to kill and destroy and blow up
the whole world it's so furious
okay now he also observed that some
caregivers cannot tolerate this there
may be too depressed to on-edge their
own child has might have been too
difficult to allow the child that moment
of primary immittance and therefore the
child quite early on has to do something
which is very difficult the child has to
become good earlier than it should so
suddenly overlaid on the true-self too
quickly is layered on what Winnicott
called
a full self and a full self smiles and a
full self does really well at school and
it looks as though everything's going
terrifically for the full self but it's
a full self and beneath is a true self
that has not had its say and such is the
nature of emotional development that the
true self is not going to lie quietly so
a large part of the problem that we've
got in the modern world is over
compliance it may look as though we're
living in a world of rebels we're not
psychologically psychoanalytically we're
often living in a world of very good
boys and girls who are nurturing serious
mental unwellness beneath their outward
competence and and great capacity to
please others because good boys and
girls know exactly what other people
need from them they've been doing this
since early childhood they they're
experts at reading what somebody walking
in the office know wants from them and
they know how to get an Ender and that's
why they're gonna be very successful but
it's difficult and some of what happens
and we pick up some of this at the
school of life I should say by the way
school life is a real institution we're
based in blooms where you can walk in
they gets like a therapy there it's a
center we run classes we've got ten
branches around the world it's a real
place you can go with your mental
unwellness
and it's fundamental I believe that
there should be places like this many
more places where we can take mental
challenges now one of the things we
often find is people who are having a
breakdown now a breakdown is an
interesting phenomenon breakdowns are
terrifically inconvenient for everyone
around the person having a breakdown
somebody was a fantastic performer at
the office or they were doing really
well at university or things were going
swimmingly for them and suddenly they're
lying in bed they're unable to speak
they don't want to eat they're furious
they're catatonic they're mumbling
incoherently no one knows
what to do now the way we like to say it
is that a breakdown is very often a
prelude to a breakthrough
there is something trying to break
through and that something can very
often be a healthy thing right it's the
true self that has not had its say and
very inarticulately and very
inconveniently because there's the AGM
coming up and there's the quarterly
reports etc something is bursting
through something needs to be heard and
we need to give that home and we don't
do it enough another psychological
dynamic to watch out for psychotherapist
talk they work wonderful term for this
of the way in which very many of us
especially if we don't understand
ourselves too much are guilty of what is
called transference
now transference is an interesting term
what it means is that you are
transferring from the past ways of
behaving and emotions that were suited
to a very difficult early the early
phenomenon and you're landing these
emotions onto a part of adult life that
is not actually called for it that
doesn't really warrant it and let me
give you example some kind of office
life so let's imagine you're dealing
with someone as you mention you a
manager of somebody and you've got a
colleague and you call them into your
office you say look I really like the
report it's fantastic done a really
great job the last couple of paragraphs
you just need to kind of tweak them
because they're not quite right it's not
it's not landing properly and they turn
around and they go what is it about you
why are you always trying to bring me
down nothing that I do is ever good
enough for you why do I not deserve to
be here like everybody else and you want
to hang on hang on and quite clearly
something is coming up from a place that
doesn't belong merely to that office at
that point something is being
transferred a sense of unworthiness a
defensive structure built up probably
before the age of five is surging forth
8:35 in the middle of a high-rise office
with a legal case pending and and
therefore I don't mean that the person's
gonna be sued but as it were these a
bunch of lawyers trying to figure out a
sensible way forward but somehow
emotions have got in the way and this is
fascinating and poignant and that's why
we're never as adult as we like to think
that we are and those who are most adult
are those who have successfully
negotiated a relationship with their
childhood self and particularly the more
damaged or tricky parts of their
childhood selves with all the unusual
demands that that will make like I want
to talk about love because relationships
you know it's been estimated that a
person's life satisfaction is dependent
up to 60% on the quality of their
primary relationship with another
another adult very striking statistic if
you gave a Martian that statistic if you
said how happy humans are is dependent
on the quality of their relationship
they would immediately deduce that human
beings must be spending at least 60
percent of their time leisure time but
also work time figuring out the problems
of relationships it's not like that at
all if you look at the modern economy
probably less than 1% of the modern
economy is devoted to trying to get
relationships working well very peculiar
statistic given what things are like for
us on the ground as it was we're living
our lives and part of the reason for
that is a movement of ideas called
romanticism which takes hold in well it
starts really the tail end of the 18th
century and we're still living in what
we could call a Romantic Age it starts
off in the minds of poets writers and
artists and it's now spread everywhere
you find romanticism in pop songs in in
adverts in everywhere it's permeated
modern culture and Romanticism teaches
us all sorts of things about
relationships there to my mind
poisons very often our capacity to have
good relationships so we're up against a
very unhelpful cultural background let
me give you a few of the key ideas of
Romanticism
so romanticism tells us that everybody
everybody has a soulmate and they're
going to find them it may take a bit of
time bit of heartache etcetera but
eventually you'll find a soulmate and
when you find your soulmate
you will never disagree them with them
on anything they will understand
everything about you and you everything
about them and they will be perfect
symmetry and loneliness finally will
come to an end that's all made where are
you gonna find them you're not going to
find them with your parents setting you
are poor any kind of rational analysis
they're gonna be found by instinct
instinct will guide you to the best
person to have 50 years of happiness
a special feeling it's interesting
you're in the 19th century heyday
Romantic literature people were always
falling in love in trains it trains a
very romantic place to do you see a
stranger there reading a book and you're
reading a book but you're actually
spying them and and they have a lovely
face and poetic eyes and before you know
you've reached your your station you
know that this is the person so that's
how you find a sensible life partner for
for 50 years the other thing is
romanticism coincides with the
secularization of society so as the
hopes and dreams that we previously
invested in gaad's starts to AB so some
of that energy is redirected towards
human beings but we now start to call
angel so we say angel' could you get
some milk from the fridge and angel how
are we going to go out tonight sir
but the problem is angels just don't
quite measure up to those lovely things
painted by Piero della Francesca so we
get mad and angels not quite doing what
it should but anyway that's an idea of
Romanticism also the notion is that when
you meet your soul mate and when you
find them angelic you're going to live
with them forever the whole thing has to
be forever if it's real it has to be
forever till death do us part
anything else is fake and it helped that
many of the romantics died quite young
so very often they'd meet and they'd
fall in love and it a little bit of
cough and then she Burke Ulysses would
set in and and after three beautiful
stupendous months the lover would die
and death environmentalism very few
romantics had jobs leaving a lot of time
to nurture one's feelings and one's
emotions go out into nature nature was a
great addition and a great catalyst of
love particularly waterfalls and the sky
at sunset it was designed to foster
these these precious emotions and then
there's a feature younger people who
don't speed block your ears a feature of
romanticism which was very distinctive a
complete union of sexes in love so
whereas for centuries sex it existed in
one place in love in another the
romantics fused the two sexes becomes
the highest expression of love and which
sounds lovely until is a bit of adultery
which suddenly starts to become not
merely a problem but a tragedy
so people are constantly killing
themselves in 19th century fiction
because of adultery it
romanticism moves adultery from being as
it were a difficulty which is
undoubtedly always been to being the
greatest tragedy that could ever be be
known you'll be telling from my tone
that I don't necessarily approve of a
lot of these romantic ideas let me pick
a whole briefly in just a few of them I
mean the notion that you're gonna find
your life partner by instinct is clearly
mad and I'll tell you why
back to Freud back to psychotherapy the
way in which we love as adults sits on
top of a base formed in childhood when
we fall in love we're not falling in
love for the first time we are refined
in love now the reason why this often
goes wrong is that the love that many of
us knew in childhood though there was
kindness and generosity and playfulness
at times there is very often also likely
to have been some more problematic
dynamics there might have been distance
there might have been depression they
might have been a certain hostility or
cynicism or brittleness whatever it may
be and what happens is that in adulthood
when we meet various people that we
think might be good for us and that our
friends might think are good for us we
simply don't have that special feeling
we don't have the instinct feeling our
feelings are quite numb you know you'll
get this when imagine you've got a
friend and they've been trying to find
the right person for ages so you set
them up on a date so when somebody's
really nice and just seems really kind
of sane and solvent and kind or a little
bit and then you call them up after the
date and you say so how did it go did
you like them and their friend goes you
probe and you're like you know and they
go well and maybe a little not sexy or
bit boring but what these are really
cover words what the friend is really
trying to tell you is I'm afraid that
this person you set me up with is simply
too healthy to produce in me the sort of
dynamics that need to be generated if
I'm to feel that I'm in love the person
is simply good threatens to be too nice
for me in order to generate that special
feeling that I need because because and
one doesn't know this consciously
because at some level love has become
associated with forms of suffering that
we don't even understand and can't even
dqo
that's why instant is such a bad idea we
need to unpick instinct because so often
it's directing us towards a recreation
of a problem rather than the recreation
of a of a solution other crazy things
you know the romantics romantics believe
that if you really love somebody you
should find every part of them perfect
and beautiful this is a very very
strange idea I mean you know sometimes
incense lovers will go love me for who I
am
love me for who I really am why don't
you love me for who I am what a mad idea
I mean who really could expect to be
loved for who they no one should be
loved for who they are all of us should
be educated this is a difference between
the ancient Greeks and the romantics the
ancient Greeks also made a great play of
love but for them love is a classroom
love is an arena in which two people can
support each other to become the best
version of themselves it is not a forum
in which to endorse everyone's faults
willy-nilly
it is a classroom love is a classroom
and the point of love is to be able to
teach and to learn and that is what
makes a so-called good lover the good
lover is a good educator okay and also
good pupil this could sound very odd I
mean imagine if you went home tonight
and you said look at listening to this
chat the funny name and he's been
telling me that love is a classroom and
on this basis I've drawn up a list and
I'm going to be talking to you tonight
for an hour and a half about your faults
and tomorrow night you it wouldn't go
anywhere because we don't believe very
unfortunately okay so many many things
are badly understood look the other
thing that the romantics have very
unhelpfully taught us is that if you are
properly in love with somebody and they
are properly in love with you they
should understand you without the needs
to speak that they should simply ensure
it and in the early days of love don't
get me wrong in the early days of love
there are some touching moments you know
you just met somebody at 3 weeks in and
it's just beautiful you're by the
riverbank and you say you know that
feeling when autumn comes and there's
that smell and they go I know exactly
what you mean I've been there before and
they just they finish your sentences and
from this beautiful beginning a
nightmare is born
and the nightmare the nightmare is that
another person can understand the
contents of your mind without using that
terribly cumbersome thing called
language and this is a real pain is that
ofcourse little children have this I
mean babies will literally believe that
their parents know what's going on in
their minds and to some extent good
parents have a good shot at guessing
what's in them as because it's not gonna
be that complicated either they've got
the light in their eyes or they're
hungry or they're thirsty or they need
to go to bed so we can make good guesses
of this but as an adult as a complex
machine that has special taste and
interior decoration in what time to
leave for the airport and how you feel
about a particular friend you're gonna
guess this know you've got it use words
unfortunately romanticism has unleashed
an epidemic of sulking and what is a
sulk a sulk is essentially a pattern of
behavior that is set in motion when you
believe that someone who loves you
should understand you there are things
you could explain but you're going to
choose not to because you're done with
explaining and they're supposed to love
you so they're supposed to know so after
they've violated your feelings the party
let's say by doing something slightly
wrong or laughing or whatever you're
gonna sit in the car and they're gonna
go darling what's wrong and you've got
nothing and then this will carry on and
you'll talk to the apartment and they'll
go come on what's wrong and you do
nothing and you'll put yourself into the
bathroom and you'll shut the door and
and they'll stop knocking at the door
and they look please just tell me what
I've done wrong
and because you're expecting as a good
romantic that they will show and
understand who you are how you are
lonely and what you're like as a human
being in your in the finest brain as a
parent might understand a child it's not
gonna work there is only one way to be
understood and that is through the
horribly cumbersome business of language
okay
a few other things I want to talk to you
about confidence one of the things that
people come to us at the school of life
with is the problem of feeling that they
don't dare to do something right they
don't to tell somebody that they really
like that they really like them or to
start a business when they really want
to start a business or to leave
when everyone leaves they're lacking in
confidence now what what do you do this
is a chronic problem also by the way
they often feel like imposters they go
like those guys over there
they're the real guys but I think I I'm
just held together by sellotape I'm I'm
not real they're real and I can never be
like them now if we were bless bless the
west coast if we were a Californian
organization we would tell people this
we would tell people you're beautiful
you're strong you're an amazing human
being
believe in yourself head out there go
for it this is disastrous advice don't
go down that road we tell people this
when they say and just I'm terrified
I've glimpsed this out of the corner of
my eye I think I'm an idiot
I'm just I think I might be an idiot
right and you know their eyes filled
with tears and and we say to them
something that sounds brutal but is
actually totally redemptive and
compassionate we say we've got news for
you you are an idiot but the good news
is we're on a planet of seven billion
idiots right we are that the human race
is obviously mired in idiocy from
beginning to end
right we walk into doors we don't
understand ourselves we don't start
other people we make catastrophic errors
we from beginning to end the whole thing
is a mess right now once we accept this
with a certain grace and indeed humor
this is the birth of humor which is one
of the most redemptive emotions we can
ever have humor towards ourselves and
humor towards others right once we can
start to accept that of course we're
idiots and that the fundamental nature
of being human is idiocy you'll just go
up and ask the person on a date because
well you know you're an idiot and it
doesn't matter they're an idiot too and
off you go
or you might go up and ask somebody if
they might be interested in starting a
business with you what does it matter
life is short we're all idiots so the
fundamental notion of confidence built
up not through an assumption of a a
perfection and our perfectibility but
precisely a confidence born of an
elegant negotiation with everything that
is imperfect in us this seems enormously
important look I want to do one more
little exercise with you because I think
it can be interesting we do a lot of
this at school Drive and it can be very
helpful you know we're often taught that
the primary problem that we have is that
we're selfish people
right we caused a piece of lamb basses
little voice at the back of our heads
like you're selfish you're always
looking out for yourself etc now this is
a hunch but I think it's a very accurate
hunch the main problem that most people
have is not that they're too selfish
most people are not anywhere near to so
there are a few outliers who make a lot
of noise and we know all about them most
of us our problem is another thing we're
not selfish enough what I mean by that
is we're not very used because we're
good boys and girls we're not very used
to putting ourselves and our needs and
our complaints and our desires
centerstage we haven't found that voice
to do that and part of the reason
sometimes while we're ill and distressed
and can't sleep and suffer from anxiety
is because we haven't paid enough
attention to us we haven't feel being
able to feel productively selfish so
what I want you to do is again pick a
stranger and for a minute or two but no
more I want you to complete the
following sentence and hear them out as
they complete the following sentence
with you if I dared to be more selfish I
would
dot-dot-dot complete that sentence now
if I dare to be more selfish I would not
go for two minutes
okay alright let's come back let's come
back together let's come back together
thank you so much for that thank you so
much thank you so much for that for that
exercise and I hope you can continue
those conversations outside because
after all this is not merely about books
this is a festival also of our
friendship we've got a little bit of
time for some questions so if you've got
a question we've got mics as well do put
up your hand and share anything ask
something we've got some some lovely
chance for some questions so go for it
yeah anybody on that side that side yes
yes hello thank you for you began your
talk by describing a scenario where I'm
sure very familiar with which is you're
at a party and somebody asks you what
you do how can I answer that without
telling them what I do um well I mean
that's a very good question you might
tell them what you do but but you might
I mean really the sincere bit is I mean
there are various replacements and some
of them sound corny they may not always
be valid etc but I mean really what you
want to do is to say something like what
are you suffering from what are you
where are you alien how how are you sad
what are you scared of I mean that's up
don't get me wrong there is a real
importance for small talk small talk is
a very important place you can be
talking about the weather and really
you're circling your own life
the angry sky the intermittent rain
these are parts of the internal world
not just the external world and so it
has its place in in positioning people
but quite quickly ultimately what we
want is is connection and an encounter
with a reality of somebody else's life
otherwise you might as well stay home
okay yeah I think there's a microphone
that might be rushing towards you so
hang on this brushing running yeah I can
hear me sorry thank you for the lovely
talk I was wondering if you could shed
some light on what composure is and how
one could become more composed well I
mean you'll you
all guess my answer the way to try and
be calm and composed is not to assume an
invulnerable stance where somehow it's
considered normal to be free of anxiety
I think you have to make your peace with
how difficult composure will be so I
would like to see the ranks of the
anxiously composed or the composedly
anxious those who know that they would
not overcome anxiety fully but have made
their peace with that and are not
anxious that they are anxious you know
so often we beat ourselves up about
emotions thinking that they don't belong
in us I also think you know if you were
to catch me at the train station after
this talk you know fighting with my
luggage and cursing and being very
anxious and ill-tempered you might think
all that guy's a real hypocrite he was
standing up on stage or telling us he
said why sounding things but but that's
not what I'm saying
I'm saying actually that what we're
constantly trying to do is is to live
wisely around and with our neurosis
rather than trying to escape
also you know lovely thing from from
Donald Winnicott a lot of parents came
to Winnicott very anxious they had small
children and they kept saying to him I'm
not a good enough parent I'm I'm not you
know doing a good job I'm not the parent
I wanted to be and he calmed them down
with a very useful phrase which has
entered common parlance which is no
child needs a perfect parent indeed to
have a perfect parent is to be on the
short road towards psychosis and that
the job the job of a parent is to let
down a child in a structured way
so to gently introduce them to the
misery of existence myself my my son
Samuel is in the room and he will attest
to the fact that I had an overly young
age I would say to that I would say to
him it's not that I'm a particularly
horrible person it's just that you're
encountering the horribleness of life
via me first but you will later see that
this is a general phenomena you just met
with it first here and and so broadly
speaking what Winnicott was saying is no
one needs perfection you just need good
enough and and so he came up the phrase
they're good enough parent and of course
it's not just a good enough parent we
need it's good good enough office
it's a good enough friend it's the good
enough lover it's look enough everything
good enough is good enough okay yeah
should we not tell our children to be
good to be well-behaved how do we deal
that apart for your screaming and well
six role isn't saying hello to an adult
we just ignore that yes that's a very
good point and and you know I don't want
to you know speak in in in praise of
that the noble savage and that and that
there should be no rules and boundaries
are very important children are very
reassured by by a certain degree of
opposition to be a child who can do
anything that they like is as madness
inducing as to be a child who can do
nothing that they like because both of
those are presenting the child either
with an extreme image of its
powerlessness or an extreme image of its
own nipa Tain's both of which fry the
mind so so it's very frightening for a
child to not encounter and know one of
the best things you can do to a child is
disappoint them sometimes firmly and
they will be grateful to you eventually
by not being mad by not being mad by the
fact that you said no but look it's a
fine balance
I think Winnicott was talking
particularly in the very early years and
you as I'm sure are a good enough parent
you'll sense when actually the child can
take it the child can take hearing that
they should be little more polite or
pull themselves together etc you'll have
an instinct and trust that instinct but
no of course there is that balance
between the true and the false self yeah
how should we deal with crushes how
should we deal with crushes a crush
enjoy it I mean what is a price a crush
a crush is a sudden encounter with
perfection in another human being you
glimpse a face in the library or on the
train or the clifden literary festival
behind the burger stand and you think
there could be nothing wrong with this
person there there is a delicacy a
kindness and a depth of this person's
eyes that just it but tokens of a
perfect human being enjoy that but
please don't believe it's true there no
the
secure for love as we know is knowledge
get to know them better and part of the
problem part of the problem of
unrequited love you know the reason why
you know you're in love with somebody
and you go out in a few days cetera and
and and then they say I can never see
you again and they run away why is that
cruel ultimately that it's cruel because
you've denied the person a sense of what
you'll really like were you doing the
washing-up and when life's got a bit
banal etc you've prevented them from
seeing aspects of you which would have
stopped them being so passionately in
love with you so that's a very cruel
thing to do so greater knowledge or
greater imagination but but let's enjoy
why not life is short
enjoy the crash I think there was a
question there lady with the glasses
yes hello and you've mentioned the early
caregivers who weren't good enough they
weren't able to parent very well and
they turned us into good boys and girls
maybe they're the parents who let us
down in an unstructured way what's the
best method of forgiving them when
they're dead and you haven't found the
right psychotherapists to enable you to
make this wrong well well okay that's a
very good question I would hazard a
guess I would hazard a guess that you're
not so much interested in forgiveness
and more interested in overcoming the
legacy that they've given you so the
grille question here I mean part
forgiveness I think you forgive this
comes naturally once yeah right so when
you once you've made peace forgiveness
will come so the break which is how do
you make peace and I think it is getting
a very secure handle on what it is that
went wrong now for some of the things
some of the it's a very strange thing
about our minds we hear the word trauma
a lot many of us are walking around with
mini traumas in certain areas and by
trauma I mean something that cannot be
thought of or something that cannot be
thought of very easily so it may take a
long long time until you're deep into
middle-age before you can for the first
time see something and and feel it for
yourself you may have known you know dad
was a bit angry or mum was a little sad
or made me feel guilty etcetera but
really to re-experience that um that's
the work can be the work of decades I
think that psychotherapy look I'm going
to show by
psychotherapy is one of the greatest
inventions of the 20th century there are
many bad therapists out there there are
undoubtedly and many of us have had bad
psychotherapy but I think the notion of
a skilled human being who will listen
and interpret your story and play you
back to you and see things that because
you're traumatize you may be extremely
clever um you can't see this is
extremely vital that's all you say what
about a friend kind of threatened of
course a friend cut it just like a
friend can't fly the plane you need a
trained pilot you know you need a
certain degree of training to listen and
replay etc so I do very much believe in
psychotherapy okay one last question I
think we have time for yeah sorry by the
way if you want to know more little
advertise I'm sorry clippin festival
you're so great if I can advertise
something we're doing the School of Life
next weekend if you want to fly to New
York you can hear me whurling on for
three and a half days about all of this
in a giant and not giant actually quite
intimate conference space but it's a
it's a giant attempt to take somebody on
a journey so lookup school of life calm
and then look up New York conference and
you can have more of this if you want
forgive the advertising pitch back to
your question sorry just talking about
your your journey yes the replacement of
religion why is it not the school of
life and death because that's really the
big mystery in that explain that's what
religion helps us with why you're not
the school of life and death school of
and death we are we are implicitly
you're absolutely right of course a
negotiation with death is I mean look
you know think of Montagnes famous quote
to philosophize is to learn to die our
acceptance of our mortality is so
central for the buddhists the goal is to
die before you die in other words to
relinquish certain sorts of unhelpful
attachment before death actually comes
so it's in everything that we do it's in
every it's behind forgiveness you
forgive when you realize you're mortal
and the other is mortal it's behind
compassion knowing that you are we are
dealing constantly with other mortal
beings if we thought that everybody was
immortal my goodness we could afford to
be cruel and we could afford to be tough
but we're not we've got a very limited
run
this planet and on that basis we need
urgently to forgive ourselves to
understand ourselves to feel compassion
for ourselves and to extend some of that
luxury towards others on that note we
have to bring it to an end please come
and get a book signed if you like it's
been such a pleasure thank you so much
different
[Music]